it's a question that's puzzled
filmmakers for generations how do you
show a cinematic divine being from Star
Trek 5 excuse me I'd just like to ask a
question what does God need with the
starship to Clash of the Titans the
movies have wrestled with how to show
God and gods on a big screen and the
hottest ticket in Hollywood the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is no exception to
this struggle Marvel Studios has already
made multiple feature film starring
members belonging to the pantheon of
Norse gods Charlie when former head of
visual development at Marvel Studios led
his team to design the cinematic
versions of Thor and his Asgardian pals
we sat down with when for an exclusive
interview and he explained that two very
important members of Thor's immediate
family almost looked very very different
Odin and Loki Thor's dad and adopted
brother respectively were first drawn in
Marvel Comics by the legendary Jack
Kirby who probably didn't draw many or
any actual mythological details to bring
them to the page both debuted shortly
after Thor's own first comic book
appearance in journey into mystery
number 83 in 1962 but even though they
both showed up right around the same
time in the funny books there looks
couldn't have been more different in
terms of design and even simple
consistency Loki's costume from journey
into mystery number 85 may not be a
pretty sight but it is an excellent
example of how to design a bad guy where
Thor wears blue red and has graceful
looking wings on his helmet Loki is a
perfect contrast to those details his
outfit consists of hues from the other
side of the color wheel green and yellow
and instead of a headpiece with wings
that angle backward his own outfit
features aggressive horns that jut out
word while Loki's look has evolved over
the years these have been constant
features that appear in nearly every
incarnation Odin on the other hand
couldn't be less consistent or defined
Odin's first appearance sporting a style
best described as comic-book Viking
stuff only reveals his head appearing in
the clouds over Thor Mufasa style
that what you have become you must take
your place in the circle of life his
next batch of appearances are no clearer
with various designs that include
assortments of helmets capes more
helmets furs and what sure seems to be a
cummerbund with a lightning bolt hastily
drawn on it it's a lightning bolt with
extra powers considering how important
and powerful
Odin is supposed to be he might want to
try getting dressed in front of a mirror
for once and maybe fire whatever
crappier Norse gods have the job of
dressing him the all father's look
continued to evolve each time he
appeared making it seem like artists
relish the opportunity to use him for
experiments new space Viking designs
even when writer artist Walt Simonson
took control of steering the Asgardian
Royal Family's adventures with Thor
number 337 Odin never stayed in one
outfit for long
Simonson's run is famous for introducing
beta ray bill frog Thor and that
incredible scene when scourge machine
guns a bunch of demons but as Odin
remains as impossible to pin down as
anyone elses when Charlie when became
the head of visual development at Marvel
Studios one of his first tasks was
adapting the mythical land of Asgard and
it's powerful inhabitants for the first
Thor movie which arrived in 2011 and
that meant trying to define the looks
for Thor's immediate family members but
before he could settle on a specific
direction when first had to find
directions he wanted to avoid that's why
he came up with this version of Thor's
villainous brother which when calls
loony Loki while loony Loki retains the
classic green and gold colors from the
comics nearly every other element seems
transformed when explained
Loki's horns are you know it's really
represented in this floating shape
that's behind him that also changes will
float back up into shapes that you'll
recognize as being his horns this is
more like how do we still capture that
character but in unique ways this
version of the character was never
really meant to show up on film
in fact this design came about before
there was a finished script and before
director Kenneth Branagh came on to
direct the project rather wen was
experimenting seeing how far out of
shape Loki could be bent before he
became unrecognizable here I was trying
to push it as far as I could
so as my god I understood the icon let
me try to
rip it as far apart from that while
still trying to maintain who that is it
probably broke at some point but that's
actually what you're trying to do is
like understand how far do you go until
it actually breaks and this is one of
those explorations of like I need to
push this when I show that to people
that are just big low-key fans they're
just like terror I'm so glad that it
wasn't like that but I mean we needed to
go there Loki wasn't the only character
to get stretched past the breaking point
because of Odin's ever-changing fashion
there's not much when could have done in
his early designs that would have been
too out of bounds it's fascinating to
imagine the Asgard when was building
early on since it seems like it would
have gone more into Thor's sci-fi
elements than the Shakespearean super
fantasy we got instead and on that note
this concept art of Odin is outfit and
its choice of furniture speaks volumes
about the movie that could have been the
MCU is filled with magic but that magic
is really science that we don't
understand right and so that was the
premise that was set up both on Iron Man
and on to Thor right so Thor's is a
magical world this realm that we didn't
understand but we wanted to still be
based in science let's look at odhh ins
chair which consists of floating
platforms that seemed to have eventually
appeared in the first guardians of the
galaxy movie for thanasis throne when
explained this design was part of an
earlier idea for how magic and science
would come together in Asgard the
Rainbow Bridge for instance would form
as floating platforms that would appear
as a person crossed it when as guards
designed shifted to the more fantasy
based style that we saw in the Thor
movies Odin's floaty throne went away
which according to when was probably
helpful for at least one actor thank
goodness for Anthony Hopkins that they
didn't have to sit on anything like that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]